let's use the nail to diagnose some nutritional
deficiencies the outside of the body gives you
a lot of clues on what's going on inside just as a
plant if there's any type of problems in the plant
can tell you what's going on in the soil all right
the first presentation is where you have this
vertical discoloration in the center of your
nail that could be a little protein that can be
low vitamin d or b12 now you're going to
be deficient in b12 if you have low protein
because b12 usually comes from animal protein
all right next presentation you have horizontal
lines that go across that can be low vitamin
b3 low calcium or low zinc now the next
presentation has to do with that little white
speck in your nail that is a zinc deficiency
mostly caused because the person is on a high carb
diet and because it takes six months for the nail
to grow you can sort of identify a time when you
had a lot of carbohydrate because if it's right in
the center it could have been three months ago all
right the next presentation is where you have this
little chip on your nail now that could also
cross over if you have brittle nails but
if you get these little chips that just you
bang your nail and then you have this little
chip that pops off that could be low vitamin
b6 or low magnesium but it can also be in this
next presentation where we're talking about
brittle nail low iron or low hydrochloric acid
now if you're low in hydrochloric acid
you're not going to be able to absorb
magnesium or iron too well so you just might
need to add more acid to be able to absorb these
minerals now if the nail is all white it could be
that you're just very protein deficient or your
kidney or your liver is damaged or you took this
antibiotic that could be causing this presentation
if the nail is really really soft okay it's
not very strong that can be low calcium
calcium gives the strength of the nail makes
it very rigid and you may need vitamin d to
help you absorb that calcium because vitamin
d helps the absorption of calcium by 20 times
in this next presentation we have a club now
kind of a box like square and that is usually
a heart problem or it could be a liver problem or
a lung issue because you don't have enough oxygen
all right next presentation is the spoon effect
if the nail starts coming up like that that is an
iron deficiency so as you can see certain minerals
or certain vitamins can create different effects
on the nail now if your nail is a bit bluish that
can be low oxygen if your nail is a bit too yellow
that can be jaundice which is a liver problem that
occurs when there's obstruction in your bile ducts
so it can also be related to your gall bladder
in which case you need bile salts in this next
presentation we have the lower part of the nail
which is either discolored or you lost that little
luna that little horizontal white presentation
at the bottom of your nail that is usually
liver cirrhosis it could be a heart problem or
diabetes now if your nail is becoming distorted
or it's excessively thick or you have
these horizontal ridges in the center part
that is usually low biotin which is a b vitamin
in this next presentation you have these vertical
red lines these are broken capillaries this is
low vitamin c if you have this condition you may
also have bleeding gums you can have little
spider veins in various parts of your body
in this last presentation we have these
vertical ridges this could be quite a few
things it could be low protein a high carb diet
could be low b12 or low iron because you're not
getting enough protein because most b12 and iron
comes from animal protein all right thanks for
watching and i will see you in the next video hey
before you go if you're benefiting from any of my
content i would love to hear about your success
story please share it in the link down below